bienvenue à la 81ème édition des Golden Globes,
je suis votre hôte Joe Koy pour le meilleur
second rôle masculin dans un film,
le Golden Globe revient à Robert Downey
[Applaudissements]
Jr ouais ouais euh pour mes conseils de carrière en duel
Rasin et Dunlap euh ils ont eu
le culot  dire que j'avais besoin de redémarrer
ma carrière, c'est tellement amusant de prouver que les agents
écrivent cette année, nous avons tous rappelé
l'importance cruciale des écrivains dans
le processus créatif pour démontrer l'
importance des écrivains et de l'écriture, nous demandons
que ce segment soit écrit non pas par
des écrivains mais  par Studio
Executives, comment vas-tu Haley, on peut
s'identifier à moi, j'apprécie les Golden Globs, nous
sommes ici avec mes collègues acteurs pour la
cérémonie de remise de prix que nous organisons ensemble
pour présenter la catégorie de l'écriture
et le Golden Globe va à Justine
Trier et Arthur
Harari.  en repensant au moment où j'ai commencé
ce projet, nous étions dans le chaos de la
pandémie et mon partenaire de vie Arur Ari
et moi, nous passons nos journées à co-écrire le
scénario de Anatomy Overfall coincé dans
notre appartement et étrangement personne n'est
mort, je me souviens que nous n'arrêtions pas de dire  ok bon
on s'amuse beaucoup mais c'est
radical et sombre
personne ne va voir ce film c'est
trop long ils parlent tout le temps il
n'y a rien un couple qui se suicide un chien qui
vomit donc je ne sais pas exactement comment
ça s'est passé  les morceaux mais merci
beaucoup de m'avoir encouragé à continuer
exactement ce que j'aime pour le meilleur
film en langue non anglaise anatomie d'
une chute merci SRA de n'avoir jamais essayé de
faire de ce personnage une héroïne parfaite
et Snoop merci d'être vous-
même juste  un chien pour le meilleur réalisateur d'un
film Christopher
Nolan la seule fois où je suis monté sur
scène auparavant, c'était en acceptant un de
ces chiens au nom de notre cher ami Heath
Ledger et c'était compliqué et
stimulant pour moi et au milieu de
En parlant, j'ai levé les yeux et Robert Downey
Jr a attiré mon attention et m'a lancé un regard d'
amour et de soutien le même regard qu'il
me lance maintenant. Je ne peux qu'accepter cela au
nom des gens, en tant que réalisateurs, nous rassemblons
les gens et nous essayons de
les rassembler.  faire de son mieux pour obtenir la meilleure
performance d'une actrice dans une comédie
musicale ou une comédie cinématographique. Emma
Stone jouant Bella était incroyable. Je
pense que c'est une comédie romantique. Je vois cela comme une
comédie romantique, mais dans le sens où Bella
tombe amoureuse de la vie.  lui-même pour la meilleure
performance d'un acteur masculin dans un film dramatique
Killian Murphy oh mon Dieu,
première question est-ce que j'ai du rouge à lèvres sur tout le
nez, je vais juste le laisser, j'ai su
la première fois que j'ai marché sur le plateau de Chris
Nolan, que c'était  C'était différent, je pouvais
dire par le niveau de rigueur, le niveau
de concentration, le niveau de dévouement, l'
absence totale d'options de sièges pour les
acteurs pour la meilleure chanson originale,
le film, pourquoi j'étais fait à partir de la
musique de Barbie et les paroles de Billy, c'est ok Phineas
OK.  merci à mon frère Phineas, tu
es la raison pour laquelle je suis ce que je suis, euh, je tiens
à remercier Greta et Noah d'avoir réalisé
cet incroyable film en écrivant cette chanson qui
m'a en quelque sorte sauvé un peu. Je suis très
excité de vous l'apporter pour le  toute
première fois pour une réalisation cinématographique et au box-
office
Barbie
moi,
merci, nous aimerions le dédier
à chaque personne de la planète qui
s'est déguisée et est allée dans le plus grand
endroit sur Terre, les salles de cinéma,
merci à Ryan Gosling pour avoir fait le plein de plage
c'est un film sur Barbie mais c'est
aussi un film sur les humains nous l'avons fait
il s'agit de vous nous l'avons fait pour vous et nous
l'avons fait avec amour et merci de l'
aimer en retour pour la meilleure
série télévisée limitée Série d'anthologie ou
film réalisé pour la télévision
boeuf, vous savez, notre émission est en fait basée
sur un véritable incident de rage au volant qui
m'est réellement arrivé, donc je m'en voudrais
de ne pas remercier ce chauffeur, monsieur, j'espère que
vous klaxonnerez et crierez et inspirerez les autres pour
les années à venir Ali
Wong j'ai vraiment besoin  pour remercier tellement Sunny
d'avoir créé un si beau spectacle
Steven
Yun, je suis juste le bénéficiaire d'une longue
lignée de compassion, d'amour et de
protection
et euh bonne volonté, donc j'apprécie cela
pour la meilleure série télévisée musicale ou
comédie,
[Applaudissements]
portez bien  Je ne sais pas pourquoi ils m'ont choisi
pour parler Je pense que je ne sais pas s'ils
croient que nous gagnerons mais je ne
sais pas que nous sommes là maintenant Jeremy Allan White Je
ne peux pas croire, euh, je suis dans ça  chambre avec
tous ces euh tous ces gens que j'ai
aimés euh tellement admirés
je suis un artiste et j'ai beaucoup de chance d'
être un artiste et je sais que nous ressentons tous
cela et donc je viens vraiment  je tiens à
reconnaître que je suis très reconnaissant envers
ma famille, euh, tout le monde chez l'ours, c'est
ma famille, je vous aime tellement, les gars,
c'est un honneur de travailler avec vous et de grandir
à vos côtés et, euh, ma vraie famille aussi,
je vous aime aussi les gars.
si j'ai oublié de vous remercier, je suis désolé
à moins que vous ayez été méchant ou quelque chose de bien, au revoir,
merci pour la meilleure série télévisée
dramatique, donc cela a été dit, mais c'est
un effort d'équipe, cette émission, nous avons décidé que c'était
le bon moment pour terminer la série et
euh c'était très doux-amer j'ai juste
adoré chaque seconde en jouant euh l'étrange
et
merveilleuse tache de graisse humaine qu'est Tom
Wan
euh
assieds-toi merci garçon
euh désolé rots la digestion IND
n'avait pas besoin de dire ça euh sinon
c'est un bon moment pour moi  J'étais, euh,
je l'ai déjà gâché, jez, tu avais
raison, tu as dit, dis simplement merci et
pars, tu avais raison grâce à la
succession. Je suis venu ici plusieurs
fois, c'est bien, mais j'ai en quelque sorte
accepté que je ne le serais jamais.  sur
scène donc c'est un bon moment suce-le
Pedro
désolé le mien
euh j'espérais en quelque sorte ne pas avoir à me
lever c'est vraiment lourd euh merci euh
cette salle est tellement intimidante je dois l'
avoir nous sommes honorés d'être ici  et
reconnaissez les performances intrépides et inspirées
d'un acteur masculin dans une comédie
musicale ou une comédie cinématographique Jeffrey Wright
Paul gamat Timothy sham et bien sûr
[Musique]
Walkin
[Musique] [
Musique] [
Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce qui se passe  Je suis gêné que les
Golden Globes n'aient pas
changé c'est un film sur un professeur j'y
joue le rôle d'un professeur toute ma famille ce
sont des professeurs, ils reviennent tous Les
générations les professeurs sont de bonnes personnes doivent les
respecter ils font une bonne chose
c'est difficile  travail donc c'est aussi pour les enseignants,
actrice de soutien féminine,
film Divine Joy Randall à Alexander
Payne, merci de m'avoir donné l'
opportunité de représenter cette
femme belle et imparfaite pour le meilleur film
musical ou comique, pauvres
choses, je voulais juste parler à Bruce
Springsteen  toute
la nuit, nous avons le même anniversaire, le 23
septembre, il est mon héros depuis que je suis
grand, de toute façon, je perds mon temps, meilleure
performance d'une actrice dans un film d'émotion,
un drame, plus
Glader, je viens de parler un peu le langage des pieds noirs,
la belle nation communautaire.
qui m'a élevé, qui m'a encouragé à continuer, continue à
faire ça, c'est un
événement historique alors que cela n'appartient pas seulement
à moi, c'est pour chaque petit enfant de Rez,
chaque petit enfant urbain, chaque petit
enfant autochtone qui a un rêve et qui se
voit  représentés et nos
histoires racontées par nous-mêmes dans nos propres
mots meilleur film dramatique
Oppenheimer ce n'est que la plus petite
partie des nombreuses personnes qui
ont fait du film ce qu'il est et euh ce que
j'ai adoré être assis ici à entendre tout le monde parler
de leur travail  euh, ce qui est si clair,
c'est que ce que nous faisons est une collaboration et
c'est incroyable et c'est excitant et je
trouve ça complètement magique euh
vous savez, Chris fait en quelque sorte ressortir le meilleur
des gens en étant lui-même le
meilleur, ce
qui enveloppe notre émission à tous.
j'espère que vous avez passé une bonne nuit. Hollywood
est de retour, bonne
nuit